[Applause]
so akash is super paranoid of um
of ai right because he read one book
about ai
and that's not true yeah i'm reading one
book about a.i
all right let's be factual about what
we're saying all right
so you read this book about ai you're
reading this book about ai
and now everything is like ai is going
to take over and
everything correct and you're very
concerned about ai
i think it's going to be lit for a
little while right and then it's going
to
you think in 15 years we everything is
ai
i think flying cars yeah i legit think
all you always add a couple more years
within five years there's gonna be
flying cars maybe ten at least fifteen
ten to fifteen standard fifteen ten
fifteen let's put money on it let's put
it okay
no no we have flying cars now they're
called planes no yeah yeah
what do you mean like [ __ ] flies i mean
you're gonna travel
yeah via flying via flight you mean
people
who's gonna travel via flight
exclusively
exclusively why would i exclusively
travel during in flight there's gonna be
faster [ __ ] on the ground what if you
had to watch this hyperloop ground
if it's ground it's going to be
hyperloop or some other street we've
never seen no you can't
you can't hold the hole
if you travel on the ground it's going
to be something we've never seen before
everything in the future that's new is
something we haven't seen before
within 10 to 15 years nobody's driving
no cookies just said
he's like i had enough of this
[ __ ] get out nobody's driving
ever like you're not allowed to drive 15
years 10 to 15 years you're not allowed
to drive
do you forget what country we're from
bro 10 to 15 years is re it's glass
closed
bro you're just saying it's dumb what do
you mean you were not allowed to drive
explain that to me because self-driving
cars are going to be so good and so much
better than regular people they're going
to be like yo it's actually a risk for
this person too
just because things are good and things
are risky
when we do it doesn't mean we're not
allowed i don't think you're going to be
allowed to drive
condescending yo but it's true and when
you put your knee up it
makes it that much more like i was
offended at least
because look you could say listen
there's no people shouldn't walk
you should just get on these conveyor
belts we'll put on the street and that's
going to be way better and then nobody
will
fall and then bump their knee and suit a
city i don't think that applies
i think that's just like a leap you
can't use your little don't applause
argument
well we would try to do that with hey
the whole time with you you that's what
you sound like when you argue
but i'm actually right i would just say
but then jeremy take out the little
walkie things but then you could be like
ah theoretically this if this if this if
this
i'm just saying what it's gonna be i
agree with the point that i think what
are you saying hold on let him let him
make his argument what's this going to
be because all you this is what your
prediction is yo in 10 years it's going
to be different
but it's going to be future in 10 years
it's going to be 20 30. i think within
the next
hey you're not gonna walk you're not
gonna sleep you're just gonna fly
all day everything's flying
time
[Laughter]
i think in the next 10 years you will
see 10 to 15 let's say you'll see
you're not gonna chew your own food
because you don't get happy you could
choke on and have to heimlich maneuver
you
so they'll chew your own food and put it
directly in your stomach it's not gonna
happen for at least eight and three
quarters
just to be clear yeah but i'm saying 15
to be safe yeah let's be safe though but
i think 20 years this makes no sense
i know yo you'll see more innovation in
the next 10 to 15 years than we saw in
the previous
100 all right bro just don't put a
timeline on it yeah
why are you like i understand you're
saying something that's nothing so if
you put a date on it
then you feel like you're being
prophetic like you're predicting nothing
right
yo there's gonna be advancements in the
future well yeah no [ __ ]
hey 10 years from now all the
advancement will happen within 10
so in this book i'm reading this is a
situation they walk you through they say
within 10 years
they convert they can barely fly you
through it they may fly you through it
bro
it's not that far we're
so you wake up yeah you're hooked up to
your body's hooked up to enough sensors
that they say oh this person didn't get
a good night of sleep last night uh-huh
so as soon as you walk out the door
ready for work
a car comes and picks you up since you
didn't get enough sleep
fresh sheets on a bed that you can sleep
in in a self-driving car
that takes you to a hyperloop station
takes you from dc
to new york in 30 minutes door-to-door
time is like
50 minutes to go to work from dc what if
my girl is the reason
why i didn't get a good night's sleep
and what if my girl also is going to dc
in the same car um how am i going
to have that locked down 16 years we'll
have the answer to that for sure
now i'm in my own car yeah i'm in my own
harbor yeah what if somebody's snoring
loud on the hype
i don't know if you're in your own
hyperloop but you're in your own car but
what if somebody's snoring loud and
hyperloop
they don't know that that's just hey the
car is
that's where you sleep is the car but we
don't know there could be construction
what if there's construction what if
they're building a double decker to the
hyperloop there's a guy with a jacket do
you think there's gonna be no
jackhammers in the future
3d printer is going to be mad quiet i
actually don't know if there'll be jack
cameras in the future
hey dude 3d printed hey do you think
that in the
in the future they'll have 40 burning
is that possible they might get to 60 if
we're being
never being realistic okay okay so
no give us more can we ask you questions
about the future and then you tell us
yeah as i read more of the book no no no
you got it now
just trust your gut and all the [ __ ]
you don't know
no you got it you got it what will food
look like in the future 3d printed food
bro
they're already doing that now are they
already doing it yeah kfc doing 3d
nuggets
is that right you know this is a story
you know this is a story
you know this is a story i will be how
crazy would i have sounded two years ago
being like yeah ksc gonna 3d print
nuggets within the next few years i
would believe it
okay i believe if you said the next
three years we would have believed it
yeah but then the next three
yeah yeah all right if you said one to
two i've been like
you this guy's crazy dude that's great
all right
all right what will planes look like
in the future
apparently yep there will be capability
to take you internationally via rocket
through spacex so you can go to
australia in like an hour
why would you go all the way to space to
go to australia
i don't think it'll actually leave the
earth's orbit it would be more similar
speed wise than sonically or whatever
but it doesn't make sense to go all the
way to space
if you don't want to go there i don't
think you've got to go to space i think
they'll just call it a spaceship
it'll be similar to a spaceship
what about a space boat
that would be sick i think they'll get
it i think they'll get there would it
not
mean to go underground all the way out
of the earth's atmosphere yo it's
talking about our space rope if you were
smart if i was spacex they're trying to
figure out how to get to australia
pulley systems just go up
waiting for the earth to come around and
then come back back
down oh [ __ ] use after fuel dude
and then you don't have to use any fuel
to come down you just gravity
yeah you know what's right australia new
zealand
[Laughter]
i thought we were being for real water
is right there and that's what you
landed
all right al do you have any scientific
questions in the future what is what
does child birth look like
yeah what's the what's the future of
childbirth answer that
you [ __ ] schmuck i think at some
point we're all dead so it won't matter
oh no but that's not 10 to 15 10 to 15
years what does child birth look like
out of the [ __ ] yeah is there anything
else in
i think a robot is delivering the baby
why would the robot deliver the baby
because why would you need a human when
ai can do it better just like surgery is
done it might be overseen by a human or
something maybe
but they have robots doing surgery but
no they don't have robots
100 they don't have robots doing surgery
no they don't look like that
what surgeries do they do i don't know
look it up though it's a thing
i don't know specific surgeries but look
at that i'll give them that though look
it up do they have a robot
an hour no i'll be knowing [ __ ] like
this is a female there's at least one
robot there once again
i don't think they're doing surgery
you've had a robot surgery
is there a surgery that they could
remove the dick from your throat
[Laughter]
i want to keep it there it's the thing
i'm sure there would be if i didn't want
it there but i like it there
okay okay do you think in the future
there will be skateboarding um for
recreation
you know i mean will they allow people
to recreate
yeah i think if it could just endanger
you it's fine but if it can danger
others
no they're gonna allow people to
recreate in the future
i think recreating will be allowed yo if
all the doctors are robots is that
is that and like i mean you already got
chinese doctors this is the next
level i mean just a little bit more
robotics are you concerned
as indians yeah how are you gonna make
your parents proud we should be you know
i think that's why we're going to tech
because we see where it's going
that's why indians are so mad about ai
because you guys are the
eye right now yeah yes we're the ni yeah
it's natural intelligence
oh my god so you guys are gonna go
somewhere else
all right my bad mark what did you
almost spell a word we're not supposed
to i don't know
holy moly okay um
now do you think i feel like i'm in the
spin cycle
yeah you're in the middle when he said
ni
right what is it natural intelligence
gotta get everybody
what terry cruz
chill yeah you're right my bad dog come
on we gotta combine our own
opportunity what is it
our own negativity conquer our own
negativity yeah okay
akash i want you to have more faith in
humanity i don't yo
i don't you don't i don't it's over you
really think
how many more years do you think the
human species has left
50.
i'm lying with that that's people oh
gosh shut up
in 50 years bro nah you guys are all
dead come on bro
i think it's a rabbin50 okay that's me
that's just my own like i haven't read
nothing
i'm just like oh 50 years or so we're
wrapping this up right now wrapping this
up right now
i kind of just beat in your wild taking
i listen wrapping this up right now
you're gonna give me any future take
that you have
and i'm gonna tell you why it's not true
okay just go any future take you have
and the dead be dead serious
that you truly believe in the future
robots doing surgery say again
or a 3d printing food one of those not
gonna happen okay go ahead
you can't 3d print certain foods which
foods reese's pieces peanut butter cups
can't do it you're absolutely blessed
yeah you can make the cub you make
peanut butter but you can't do it
together and what's the name of it
reese's peanut butter cup there we go
peanut butter cups you need both
nah the only thing you won't have is the
wreath everything else is going to be
there
go anyway that's next keep going next
next thing in the future won't happen
go i dare you i want to take all his
takes
put it in a time capsule and then bury
it
and then in 10 to 15 years open up for
the dumbest hero
and he's gonna read everyone how does it
feel akash
scoreboard
[Laughter]
okay go go guys go go go self-driving
cars self-driving cars
what about it that's now that's not the
future wrong
no every card are the majority of cars
would be self-driving no
that's a stupid one why because
the majority went from everyone to
because if somebody said to you and
you said every car if somebody said to
you say every car stick the landing
don't be like a little bit of this
of course you can always make that go
every car is self-driving in 10-15 years
wrong why is that because i could keep
my car
do you have a car do you have a car i do
it i do
i do have a car what kind of car i have
a tesla truck
what feature does that tesla truck have
as a feature but it's not only that
i can also do natural driving
[Applause]
what was going to be your plan did you
know what that was going to be your plan
that was a girl really liking that logic
i just
yeah all right about everything
more features
i was consent bro go go go go go go go
go next one go how are you going to get
around your tesla truck what was your
plan
for parking sorry what was your plan are
you ever going to have it parked you're
just going to have it
move around and self-drive while you
like a shark yeah
while you do work and then come back to
the car this is your idea
i'm never going to park in new york are
you predicting the future and i'm
telling you why it's not or
is this a different game i just flipped
it oh now it's the flip okay
okay that's a good point that's a good
point that is a good point okay listen
um that's not the game that we're
playing so let's go back
lift it back okay over the top okay
so no another prediction go any
prediction you want for the future go
i'd probably go i've already knocked
both of those out of the park you were
somewhere over there
first you said all cars are gonna fly
and now he's trying to sell
driving like let's go all self-driving
flying
cars yeah wheels all together
no more wheels no more circular shits
that's a good question no more circles
how are you gonna find those dots to put
on your legs
[Laughter]
for as long as we're around we're going
to have these dots okay go go go
go go go go go next prediction go
3d printing as opposed to construction
we're just building buildings 3d
that already exists again no yeah no
no i got them i got them no one does
actually
i got it doesn't exist what the 3d print
is
bricks or little pieces of the building
and then they gotta build them together
yeah
you can't just 3d print a building
hey mark hey get in there
the whole thing right what is the whole
thing the whole [ __ ] structure of the
building and you don't think it's going
to be there's not going to be
construction
yeah i think yeah that's a lot i think
it's going to be all 3d printing
no then how do you put it together there
has to be some construction
how do you put the doorknob on the door
3d printing y'all no
that's not fun okay how do you do this i
got a mouse okay i got him
how do you do this how do you put the
thing where you fold the towel after you
use it in the bathroom
i don't got them
you know it would have been a good
question you know i thought
no way
that [ __ ] needs to be screwed in oh you
really trusted him
on the buzzer
[Applause]
you got the wall and you got the thing
that holds the towel
that [ __ ] is impossible to put on even
by myself
you couldn't even install the bidet i
didn't try
wait did you not install it no yo
bring that [ __ ] let's put it in here
yeah i could you gotta put in the public
bathroom yeah yeah
we all should tell you honestly i think
that's a good idea
that's a great idea what if you pee on
the part where the water shoots out
because then the last guy's
gonna hit your ass it self cleans i
don't know if i believe all that yeah it
self cleans
oh and
we needed to get out one we needed to
get that one all right
listen i gotta go all right okay so last
one
yeah i got no more man i'm out i gave
you all of them
all of them i've read about the world
ain't changing them the world ain't
changing
that's what i'm trying to say get used
to it get comfy you're going to live in
this for your whole life
oh i got one i go go this is one of the
hot guys tell me there's a future where
there's no more
cash money
let me think about it let me think about
it keep going you think
money doesn't exist at all that's not
what i said cash money
no more cash yeah i'm sorry cash money
does not exist at all
what about all the cash that we
currently have pull it out of
circulation
yeah and that money will be put into our
bank accounts by the government
yeah no how how are rappers gonna flex
some videos
swipe that [ __ ] bro on the butt crack
cars dog yeah
takashi is going to have an extra lambo
in his video
self-driving ass lambo you know i'm
going to say in how many years
because his [ __ ] is 10 15. 10 to 15. no
i don't know the time in 100 years yeah
there's no more money it's stupid
that's idiotic 100 years what a [ __ ]
bitch-ass estimation that was
100 years
the [ __ ] 80s oh you [ __ ]
you saw a new millennium in the last
hundred sounds like a scoreboard is
coming up dude have some balls
god damn son corona all right all right
all right 200 years i think it's 200
yeah
i think within 200 years there's no more
money
actually 100 i don't think in 200 years
you don't know a single thing about the
future ai you just add five
in front of it and then you think you're
smart there's gonna be no more toilets
in ten years we're just gonna take [ __ ]
not even 250 and you say in 200 years
that's both
longer than 250 1776
america's when we got here i'm nervous
when we
got here son america is where we
are
he was like oh this feels very american
to me i know you just took my word on
the ground
american bro what you just took my word
on the math on the math
yeah yeah i i know drew's not great at
history mad because he accidentally said
slavery was like 100 years ago or no he
said 400 years ago
i just did that because that's what van
latham said to [ __ ] kanye west
okay i thought van had his [ __ ]
numbers down
i think that he knows about that more
than me yeah
but then when was it i don't know no
no no it was it was a little too close
bro it was it was yeah we said 150 but
it was 250 right yeah
like that yeah wait a minute hold on no
it was nice we said 250 we're like yeah
it was mad long ago
and you're giving just a little bit less
time for cashless societies
with your predictions that's why that's
the thing you're not aggressive that you
think you're making some big predictions
but you're still saying
i'm the opposite guy i'm the guy that
makes no prediction yeah you're like
a prediction no i think it's not going
to change a.i i don't think anything
we don't want to come up on it we don't
wipe our butts anymore
that's what he says within the next two
weeks
a lot of changes coming up boys
predictions
[Applause]
i'm the one saying it's not going to
change their lifetime that's the most
brave prediction
that's not brave enough that's the most
brave
hey listen listen yo i just realized how
brave i am
hey cookie shut up you dog
[Laughter]
listen listen i just realized
i was too excited i couldn't get the
word right i was too excited it
nothing you think a little [ __ ]
robot's gonna replace you stupid
that's how dumb you are you think me me
me me me
that's the point you're excited about
that's the difference
this is what i'm excited about this is
bravery that's the point of your
exercise investing in humanity you're a
whole cowardice is investing in
technology
howard's been a win cowards be winning
i thought by this time you'd be on my
side
i didn't think you're gonna stay double
down on that i'm investing in humanity
are you saying by 22 20 she's going to
be the same you stupid what the [ __ ] did
he just say with that number
two one 200 years from now 200 years
from i'm not going to be around yeah
you're gonna be the same nobody will be
able to stand with you
listen how smart i am i just made a
prediction neither of us could prove
yeah there's gonna be no more oxygen
that's what you sound like you smell
like [ __ ] greta thunder you stupid
[ __ ]
the robots are coming let's stop
using our food oh my god yeah
no more toilet paper boys seriously why
not end the next week bro
no more toilet paper remarks just watch
that's all i'm saying your prediction
way dumber than mine no you have the
dumbest prediction yours is the dumbest
yours are the dumbest yours is the
dumbest you can't even spell 200
[Laughter]
but for real though think about it you
have to think about it you're not
thinking you're letting the ais do all
the things
that's what you do i'm thinking you need
some ai to do your thing what i'm doing
is i'm holding this up i won't even let
this you do ai for my mic
sometimes you gotta hit from all angles
bro you just gotta hit all angles
this is all i'm saying i wrapped this up
yo
cookie cookie cookie is struggling
but don't let her hair get on her listen
to this nonsense for real dogs for real
yeah i mean this [ __ ] yeah
this is serious you need to have some
balls in your predictions
your [ __ ] is ballistic nah nah or not
dumber than mine
it's my short tail it's so short you
know what's happening
if you go to the side you have no pants
on that's good oh my balls be a little
squashed
in all seriousness dude yeah you have to
realize your predictions
cowardly bro your predictions are stupid
and bitch-ass
no no 200 years is mad time no no but
here's the thing about my mom i think
we'll go cashless within
100 no 200 years you [ __ ] listen you
said this listen listen i think
i believe in you man i believe a cash
flow society will come i believe you're
the one that's making these predictions
i'm saying this [ __ ] you're the one out
here we're gonna fly
everybody's everybody's a car it's not
two centuries and i think my prediction
will come true bro
no that's not gonna happen you're the
one making [ __ ] ai
additions that's one word i don't know
what happened
i'm doing half right there
here's the deal y'all heard that part
yo look here's the deal listen my
prediction is [ __ ]
man no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no back up back up you're not
even taking away cash
no no listen listen this is your
prediction your prediction
is you're going to give up and let a
robot [ __ ] your [ __ ]
my prediction is humans me i know me in
10 to 15 years i'm fighting for this
i'm not gonna let humans take over
you're liking terminator 2 when the
robots were walking
you just scooped into your [ __ ] and
you pulled it wide open for them to just
[ __ ] you in it right
that's why i'm saying mine is actually
more brave now yours is adorable [ __ ]
your [ __ ] is adorable i'm gonna fight
i'm gonna fight to survive i'm gonna
fight for humanity you're out here just
like yo do whatever
tell me what to do government's gonna do
it that's why i'm saying you need to
fight bro
you need to fight for your jobs you need
to fight for your jobs in india
yo podcasts are good no but indians i'm
talking about indians
we're gonna be fine we're all gonna go
to tech that's what we do i don't know
bro what are we doing i don't know i
think indians
you guys white people are you gotta stop
selling out indians bro that's why
people start
important thing like you gotta stop
selling out indians right now
you gotta stop yo
that's our job that's our job so listen
they're going to start replacing the
farms the call center farms with
artificial intelligence bro
who going to program your artificial
intelligence indians these people i
don't know
indians yo i listen listen i'm just
saying you gotta be on the side
of your people bro yeah yeah that's the
side of my people is ai
whoa dude they're going ai y'all are all
[ __ ]
wow i'm sorry that's [ __ ] up bro sold
all your that's
[Applause]
i got your back bro
listen i got your back bro and you speak
you speak it right i speak urdu
yeah say something real quick
hey what'd i say y'all
hey what i say
nah in all seriousness bro anything you
want to take back bruh
no i stand by all of it anything you
want to take back i do want to take one
thing back
what's that i think that i i want to
extend my prediction oh wow you're going
to make it even
more [ __ ] i want to extend my
prediction to
one is a century 100 years
yeah what's a thousand a gig
it's a millennia i'd like to extend my
i think human beings
are going to be driving whatever the
[ __ ] we're driving
for the next half
millennia how long is that
at least five hundred years yeah five
cents trying to make sure you knew
five centuries too yeah okay do you know
why it's century
cent is one
and what is
well it's actually yeah century nice
it's a hundred one
plus ninety-nine is a hundred yeah yeah
yeah
you know what that means in urdu
[Laughter]
all right we gotta stop this podcast
we've gone on too long uh guys we love
you
uh we appreciate you um
i have nothing else to say we've said
everything okay
akash is there anything that you'd like
to say i stand by everything i said you
know when they're listening to this
podcast
when in the future yo factual
toilet paper alyssa actually yeah don't
bail toilet paperless
i'm out of the house
don't fail about it we're spinning
together scoreboard
all right y'all peace you